zone europe avec le soutien du fonds
citoyen franco allemand
penser
[Musique]
jallet
feist
[Musique]
allo vie commune bonsoir et bienvenue
dans une europe sur radio sensations en
association avec tv 78 une émission
spéciale réalisée ici à berlin
l'allemagne est membre de l'union
européenne depuis 1958 membres de
l'espace schengen depuis 1995 et adopter
l'euro le 1er janvier 1999
dans cette émission nous vous emmènerons
à la découverte de la capitale
berlinoise puis nous nous intéresserons
aux relations franco allemandes avec nos
différents invités du centre français de
berlin et de l'académie européenne de
berlin et puis rester avec nous jusqu'à
la fin de cette émission nous vous
proposeront un voyage gastronomique
saône robe sûr sensation
e
ce lieu rendu célèbre par les films
d'espionnage checkpoint charlie
c'est l'un des lieux les plus
emblématiques de la guerre froide ce
poste-frontière établi en 1961 marque la
division entre les secteurs russes et
américains zone europe avec le soutien
du fonds citoyen franco allemand
[Musique]
ouattara
acheter et à
et les mains
mais un
les mains
florian stand man bonjour bonjour alors
vous êtes le directeur du centre
français ici à berlin l'un de vos but
c'est de contribuer à l'esprit européen
l'amitié entre les peuples bien sûr
alors est-ce que vous pouvez nous
expliquer quelles sont vos missions plus
concrètement et nous présenter le centre
français de berlin qui a fêté ses 60 ans
l'été dernier tout à fait oui merci à
d'abord pour voilà pour l'interview
alors le centre français de berlin c'est
un
centre de jeunes et un centre culturel à
but non lucratif donc le bâtiment ici
qui fait justement là cette année ses 60
ans a été construit par des alliés
français qui étaient stationnés dans le
nord de berlin donc sous le gouvernement
militaire et avec le retrait les des
gouvernements se sont dit qu'est ce
qu'on fait avec cette infrastructure
parce qu'on a là cinq étages avec un
engagement collectif on a une salle de
restauration dans les salles de
séminaires nbs salles de cinéma salle de
spectacle et se sont dits de créer un
centre franco-allemand à 50 50 % pour
justement travail et pour l'esprit
européen les amitiés des peuples et des
changes jeunes la mobilité
professionnelle des jeunes donc
concrètement en gère beaucoup de
programmes et des projets
entre les deux pays et pour l'europe
donc par exemple programme voltaire les
échanges scolaires entre les deux pays
pour toute l'allemagne et la france en
un bureau de mobilité ou en voilà
soutient les jeunes qui veulent partir à
l'étranger pour y faire un stage à se
passe d'ailleurs ce bureau de mobilité
pour soutenir les jeunes alors c'est
vraiment très complètement cherche une
famille d'accueil chercher les
entreprises chercher des places de stage
travail avec les écoles avec les jeunes
avec des parents donc il ya beaucoup
travaillé autour de ça et surtout dans
un domaine où il ya très peu de jeunes
qui qui partent à l'étranger donc
l'artisanat la formation professionnelle
accueillait aussi des français beaucoup
beaucoup et tout à fait donc il ya déjà
un berlin entrer beaucoup de jeunes
français qui viennent ici vous pourrez
un stage est généralement qui veut
partir mais aussi des échanges de jeunes
c'est-à-dire en géant le partenariat
entre la ville de paris il avait le
berlin au nouveau la jeunesse donc au
niveau du théâtre danse musique
voilà dans tous les domaines vraiment
l'été change donc dix jeunes qui rend
compte par exemple du français du design
on dit dans notre pays aussi donc on
fait beaucoup des changeurs aussi avec
un des pays tiers et aussi la promotion
voilà d'un centre franco-allemand
central international avec un programme
de formation culturelle
autour des francophonies mais aussi les
théâtres la lance avec un cinéma et un
centre qui accueille aussi des
séminaires des formations donc avec un
hébergement aussi collectif justement
donc les séminaires ces formations c'est
pas que pour les jeunes n'y a pas que
les jeunes qui sont qui sont visés ici
vous organisez peut-être des échanges
aussi avec des professionnels des
enseignants peut-être aussi qui viennent
qui viennent ici tout à fait will hunt
en travail le groupe cible
principalement chez les jeunes il faut
dire mais aussi tous les multiplicateurs
les enseignants donc tout titre avait
autour de ça aussi mais aussi une partie
voilà des gens qui sont engagés dans le
franco-allemand qui s'engagent pour
l'europe et pour un peu le côté non but
lucratif on peut dire mais aussi des
touristes on peut les accueillir ici
mais c'est vrai que notre groupe cible
vu que c'est une structure à but non
lucratif c'est quand même la jeunesse
vous disiez la culture c'est quelque
chose de très important ici au centre au
centre français de berlin
vous parliez de votre salle de cinéma
mais également des résidences
artistiques qui ont lieu qui ont lieu
ici en quoi c'est important de de
promouvoir la culture dans un centre
franco allemand alors c'était des
départs en fait il ya 60 ans déjà
l'objectif c'est à dire un peu la
séduction il dans des moments vraiment
mis la séduction des allemands par pas
la culture française à l'époque bon ça a
changé avec le temps parce que
maintenant c'est devenu beaucoup plus
une culture non seulement française et
francophone mais aussi
valent un centre culturel local aussi
donc tous les initiatives locales sont
aussi les bienvenus et voilà c'est déjà
dans le nord de berlin il ya très peu de
centres culturels donc ça il faut dire
on est dans un quartier qui en pleine de
développement leveling mais il ya
d'autres endroits croyais spectre est ce
un autre lieu à berlin où il ya beaucoup
de centres culturels et donc on à la
salle des spectacles avec la salle de
cinéma donc avec une programmation aussi
très intéressante aussi pour tout le
monde ya des festivals et la berlinale
qui vient par exemple en février si il
ya maintenant aussi avec des studios de
de danse aussi des résidences qui
s'installe pendant quelques jours ou
quelques semaines ici au centre donc on
a vraiment une toute une gamme confort
aussi pour les artistes et la population
locale il ya un autre engagement que
vous donnez ici c'est en faveur de
l'environnement et du développement
durable vous accompagnez certaines
initiatives de quartier et pour la
préservation de la biodiversité est ce
que vous pouvez nous en dire un peu plus
alors oui ça c'est des puits on peut
dire cinq six ans on a vraiment un focus
là dessus donc déjà produit notre propre
miel sur le toit on 1,16 ruche parce
qu'ici on est en train deux grands parcs
et voilà on a beaucoup de d'abeilles qui
sont sous notre toit ils se sont
vraiment très à l'aise et produit
beaucoup de l'air beaucoup de miel
quand vont aussi dans des petits
magasins autour du centre on a un jardin
partagé sur notre parking parce qu'un
grand espace de parking et puis on s'est
rendu compte que les gens y passent ici
sans vraiment s'intéresser au lieu donc
qu'on a demandé qu'est ce que vous
voulez vraiment faire et ce rendu compte
qu'un espace où on peut voilà qu tv les
propres tomates mais aussi avoir un lieu
où les gens et s'échange autour d'un
espace très écologique donc on a on a
maintenant un grand jardin avec une
cinquantaine de voisins voisines qui
sont vraiment très engagé et à la plaine
initiatives autour d'eux dans ce jardin
landes donc c'est un peu autogéré en
fait par les voisinages un peu dire mais
on a plein de choses qui se passent dans
le
dans le jardin après on a d'autres
initiatives par exemple on a aussi un
vélo on peut transporter les choses à
louer ici gratuitement donc il ya
beaucoup de petites initiatives en plus
que se rajoute à notre vie quotidienne
c'est important de faire ces initiatives
autres pour promouvoir le centre oui
tout à fait parce que c'est vraiment un
lieu ici on
voilà une bonne attraction pour des
francophones des français qui viennent
sur damas mais aussi pour le voisinage
locales aussi pour les gens qui
s'intéressent à la culture aussi pour
voilà les amants aussi pour les autres
européens donc on a aussi par exemple le
volontariat ou une jeune russe qui vient
ici peut faire un stage dans une crèche
ou une volontariat dans un volontariat
dans une crèche donc il faut avoir toute
une gamme tout une des actions très
diversifiés pour justement avoir un
centre un lieu de rencontre pour tout le
monde on va s'intéresser un peu plus à
vous à présent j'ai lu que vous étiez
n'y ait ni pardon en basse-saxe d'une
mère française et d'un père allemand
vous avez étudié à l'université de
sarrebruck à la frontière
franco-allemande est ce que cette
relation franco allemande était naturel
pour vous et c'était une évidence
finalement
je sais pas si c'est une évidence en
fait b ancian voilà on remarque si on
regarde vraiment l'histoire aussi entre
les deux pays moi je trouve ça assez
très remarquable enfin d'avoir comment
par exemple on regarde la famille de ma
mère en fait née en dans la manche en
normandie des émigrés aux citoyens voilà
ils sont allés en angleterre elle a
rencontré mon père qui avait manqué à en
avoir avec la france avant donc moi je
trouve c'est assez unique en fait
l'histoire entre les deux pays et donc
c'était peut-être une évidence que je
mette un ca ce côté franco allemand et
après je suis dit voilà je fais un stage
ici au centre français il ya quelques
années
et voilà c'est assez unique aussi
l'histoire du centre l'histoire de
berlin voit là le rapprochement parce
que quand même avec ce côté les alliés
sur place avec des gens occupés aussi
mais après ce sont devenus des amis et
je voulais donner ça un peu ou
voilà des futures générations et c'est
pas évident pour la jeunesse aujourd'hui
de se rappeler de toute cette histoire
des deux pays et donc c'est pour ça il
faut fouiller travailler quoi donc voilà
bah merci beaucoup florian langmann
d'avoir été avec nous sur sensations je
rappelle que vous êtes directeur du
centre français de berlin et pour en
savoir plus sur vos actions et celle du
centre français un site internet
centre-tir et francais.de merci beaucoup
sous une robe sûr sensation
[Musique]
c'est chaud
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
silvio
liste side gallery c'est un
incontournable de berlin du street art
sur 1,3 km à ciel ouvert on se retrouve
devant des vestiges du mur de berlin
cette peinture est sans doute l'une des
plus connues c'est le baiser fraternel
entre l'ancien dirigeant de l'union
soviétique léonid brejnev et l'allemand
heinrich junker
sous une robe sûr sensation
[Musique]
longuet
[Applaudissements]
me dira-t-on
m
soit
[Musique]
e
ado ich je suis avec christiane johan
bonsoir namco d'argent saisine théâtre
victor vous êtes le directeur de
l'académie européenne de berlin berline
l'académie européenne de berlin pourriez
vous nous expliquer vos missions oui
volontiers nous sommes un centre de
conférence qui promeut la formation
politique européenne à berlin notre
tâche consiste d'un côté a présenté ici
à berlin les sujets liés à bruxelles et
à l'europe entière d'un autre côté nous
parlons de ce qui se passe à berlin dans
les rues dans les quartiers dans les
voisinages ce sont des sujets dont on
parle au niveau européen on échange avec
les gens afin de rendre l'europe plus
compréhensible ainsi nous pouvons créer
l'europe ensemble
weibring europa qu'est ce que l'europe
apporte aujourd'hui aux citoyens
allemands et qu'est ce que l'europe a
changé europa et randa
est au rouge peut être arrêter sa liste
et intégration d'un point de vue
historique
l'intégration de l'allemagne dans une
robe commune et le mérite le plus grand
que nous associons à l'europe le fait de
pouvoir vivre en paix de pouvoir donner
une interview à une radio française de
pouvoir être des amis aujourd'hui au
delà des frontières
que des allemands travaillent en
république tchèque que des polonais
travaillent en allemagne que les
frontières puisse être traversé tous les
jours sans vraiment se rendre compte où
est la frontière réellement cela a
changé avec le co vie d'un c'était une
période où beaucoup de gens se sont
rendu compte à nouveau qu'il y a des
frontières avec des soldats qui la
contrôlent qu il y à des mesures
différentes pour lutter contre la
pandémie de l'autre côté de la frontière
c'était important pour comprendre quelle
serait la situation si l'europe n'était
pas uni nous avons également vu comment
l'europe s'est soudé en plus de la
possibilité de voyager et de travailler
il est aussi bien de pouvoir faire des
études on souhaite une chose qu'on
oublie souvent et dont on s'aperçoit
seulement quand elle ne l'est pas c'est
la paix que nous avons en europe depuis
beaucoup d'années justement grâce à
l'europe donc le rap est importante
l'europe est très importante et devient
de plus en plus importante et sera
toujours important à l'avenir surtout
quand on voit comment la chine développe
ses propres stratégies qu'à l'est il ya
des pays qui profitent du désordre qu'à
l'ouest les états unis ne se soucient
plus autant de nous mais qu'il se tourne
vers l'ouest la chine le pacifique c'est
pour cela que l'europe ne devient plus
importante car même si nous sommes de
grands pays comme la france ou
l'allemagne nous ne pourrons plus nous
battre au sol nous devons nous présenter
de façon unie et défendre nos valeurs
communes ensemble europa et zaire
concrètes young man show
l'europe est quelque chose de très
concret pour les jeunes mais également
pour votre génération avec la monnaie
commune et la liberté de circulation
parfois cela prend beaucoup de temps et
nécessite même de long combat pensez
vous que les jeunes oublient cela qu'ils
oublient l'europe
la auf die zeit manchmal la langue comme
fun
d'ex d'audace young later d'affaires
games
europe à
s'assagir c'est une question difficile
et occupe pas mal car nous faisons de la
formation politique ça veut dire que
nous voulons parler politique avec les
gens et nous voulons les aider à prendre
de bonnes décisions et nous voulons
créer de l' échange un discours où
toutes les personnes sont entendues ou
la majorité je décide mais où la
minorité protéger afin d'y parvenir nous
devons avoir la même compréhension sur
nos objectifs ce sont les personnes d'un
certain âge pour lesquelles il suffit de
voir le drapeau européen pour se
rappeler ce que cela représente les
étoiles la couleur bleue ils ont vécu la
deuxième guerre mondiale leurs parents
leur en ont parlé mais cette génération
est en train de disparaître et comment
apprendre à une personne de 15 ans ce
que signifie l'europe qui voit le
drapeau européen 300 fois par jour car
il se trouve sur tous vos billets sur
nos plaques d'immatriculation sur
beaucoup de produits sur chaque
emballage de l'est on peut en trouver ça
veut dire qu'un drapeau européen ne
suffit plus et que nous devons trouver
des moyens pour faire connaître le sujet
de l'europe à travers des thèmes
concrets cela peut être les friday for
future et la protection de
l'environnement où la classe metter
l'histoire de georges floyd est une
histoire qui se reproduit
quotidiennement en europe les gens sont
discriminés ou n'ont pas les mêmes
droits à cause de leur couleur de peau
de leur origine ou de leur orientation
sexuelle je pense que nous devons
aborder ces sujets concrets expliqué
qu'avec une europe unie en paix qui
partagent les mêmes vins or comme
l'égalité la liberté et l'état de droit
avec ses valeurs et cette base nous
pourrons surmonter ses problèmes plus
facilement ces problèmes peuvent tous
nous concerner le drapeau européen ne
suffira pas il faut aborder les sujets
concrètement via olten ait eu une
berline nous sommes aujourd'hui à berlin
vous avez de bonnes adresses et de bons
plans que vous pourriez partager avec
nous radio sensations et les
téléspectateurs de tv 78 quelles sont
les choses à ne pas rater à berlin selon
guernesey soochow from tv 78 va zidane
mousser in berline
je suis né à berlin
et j'y ai grandi je vous recommande bien
sûr les monuments connus comme la porte
de brandebourg la colonne de la victoire
l'alexander platz mais on peut profiter
de berlin aussi en allant dans les bois
et les parcs de bernard
c'est une ville très verte ou en sortant
du tir gahtane berlin un de nos plus
grands parcs on arrive directement à
tempel gopher feld où on peut faire du
vélo du cerveau lens je pense que la
meilleure façon de vivre berlin est de
combiner la nature avec le côté urbain
du alexanderplatz de la friedrichstrasse
à kuffour steendam c'est ça qui fait le
charme de berlin qu'il n'y a pas un seul
centre à voir mais qu'il y en a
plusieurs qu'on peut visiter de façon
individuelle les mongols dunkerque et
sternis one
in einer zidane tati actes hors d europe
1 michel academy berline 100
merci beaucoup christiane yoann je
rappelle que vous êtes le directeur de
l'académie européenne de berlin si vous
voulez en apprendre plus sur l'académie
européenne de berlin on peut visiter un
site internet uab étiré berlin.de
ajuster sa
berline sont un peu et où il ya merci je
vous remercie merci beaucoup zone europe
avec le soutien du fonds citoyen franco
allemand
nous sommes ici à berlin au restaurant
pastis nous allons rejoindre tout de
suite vincent garcia c'est le chef et
propriétaire de ce restaurant et il va
nous montrer sa recette des eaux
bénédicte
[Musique]
chérif et vincent du restaurant pastis à
berlin on va vous présenter l'oeuf
bénédicte qui fait partie des grands
classiques du petit déjeuner du dimanche
midi au pastis
c'est un plat qu'on propose en dehors de
la carte
très souvent tous les dimanches midi
principalement et on va vous le faire
vous le faire en live voilà deux oeufs
pochés sur une petite brioche avec des
épinards et une bonne sauce hollandaise
que je vais vous montez
devant la caméra voilà bon appétit à
l'avance le principe il est facile
à on va y arriver
il me faut voilà ils sont prêts donc
le principe de l'oeuf poché ces deux cas
cce en cassolette comme vous voyez de
faire bouillir l'eau vinaigrée
voilà en ce temps
tout
on va se faire poêler une petite brioche
au beurre tranquille bon alors vous
voyez l'eau
lola est en train de bouillir
donc là on coupe ça vous il faut juste
que ce soit frémissement de manière à
part brusquer l'oeuf
au congrès m approcher
[Musique]
l'oeuf poché ces deux minutes pour être
tranquille c'est ce qui est mieux une
donne deux tranches de brioche
et une petite casserole pour les
épinards kiki
donc on va mettre
pareil pour les épinards
je voulais un petit morceau de beurre
aussi pour les épinards alors nous on
sale le beurre
voilà
ça c'est pour les brioches et ça c'est
pour les épinards tu mets les échalotes
et l'ail tranquille
la tranche de brioche
ma chérie c'est nickel il nous faut
juste un peu d'ail ou d'échalote
voilà on est bon
voire le réveil nous avertit que la
cuisson des oeufs est terminée
donc on met les a écoutés
[Musique]
je
donc on finit les épinards les épinards
on a assaisonné le beurre c'est fait que
normalement il n'y a pas besoin de ré à
ces zones et les épinards
ils n'ont pas besoin de beaucoup
d'assaisonnement c'est la matière grasse
et déjà un ces zones est
là et prennent bien le goût
de l'oignon et l'échalote
voilà on est bon donc la petite brioche
et tranquillement au beurre
voilà tel bacon
super
week-end c'est juste pour donner un
petit côté
un petit côté bacon grillé en fait c'est
du jambon serrano
[Musique]
voilà et voilà c'est tout bon appétit
les eaux bénédicte
[Musique]
et
zone europe / sensations
[Musique]
quoi
derrière moi le palais du reichstag il a
été construit au 19e siècle il a été
incendié en février 1933 il abrite
aujourd'hui le bundestag c'est
l'assemblée parlementaire allemande
l'équivalent de l'assemblée nationale
zone europe avec le soutien du fonds
citoyen franco allemand c'est la fin de
ce numéro spécial de zone europe
réalisée avec le soutien du fonds
citoyen franco allemand et de la région
ile de france vous pouvez retrouver
cette émission podcast audio et vidéo
sur notre site et notre application
radio sensations également sur tv 78
rendez vous la semaine prochaine mais
surtout n'hésitez pas à réagir avec le
hashtag jf à 2022 sur les réseaux
sociaux très bonne soirée
sonne robe sûr sensation
zone europe avec le soutien financier de
la région ile-de-france
zone europe avec le soutien du fonds
citoyen franco allemand